[Music]
could you please give me your
three-minute commercial mm-hmm okay tell
me about yourself
soup to nuts all right moved my entire
childhood so every year from 4th to 12th
grade I was in a different school so I
was the perpetual new kid I think what
that did is perfect my ability to stand
on the outside of the room and look in
and really listen understand motivations
understand sort of the dynamic which
served me well later in life at the time
I went kicking and screaming I have a
love it started very young in life for
what makes businesses great so as I went
through college I was fortunate to have
a great business professor who really
cultivated that in me so I'd have to
report to her every week what my
favorite business was why what were they
doing differently and along that way
made a unilateral decision that I was
gonna go work for Merck so she thought I
should probably brought options it
wasn't such a slam-dunk I told her no
I'm gonna work for Merck they weren't
hiring when I got a school but eight
months later they were and I got the job
called her up said I got that job that
you said I might not and she said great
we're going out to dinner and you're
buying winter work from work started in
pharma because it was fortunes most
admired company that's why I went there
I want to learn from the best I thought
I would actually take it elsewhere and
apply it didn't really think I was going
to be so fascinated with the science
fell in love with the science and the
innovation what it could mean in
people's lives loved what Pharma had the
capacity to do hated how they got it
done in the bigger companies so I made
the leap went smaller smaller smaller
smaller until I ultimately was may be
crazy enough to start it for myself
built two businesses both in sexual
health people say why I say Irish
Catholic of course built a business late
with the only long-acting testosterone
for men and that made me on the path of
watching this emergent science for women
when the drug when this drug was put on
the shelf by the company that invented
it I made a decision to sell that off
and take it on and got the only ever
drug approved for sexual desire and
women sold that business and
now as a pass-through do nothing but
spend my time reaching my hand back and
trying to get female founders there - my
kind of outcomes faster than I got there
myself
you